FINILY ONE OF THEMARTT
RIGHT IF YOU' INTESTED IT ALL, C
>>ARENTS ARE TING UP THERE
SCHOOL BODS, PULLING THEICHILDR
THEY DN'TWANTHEIR CHILDREN
TO BINDORINATED BY A CRAZY
PEOPLE.
THE SCALE OF ITHE JOINS US
VERY THINK Y SO MU R
MING ON.
SO H BIG HASOMESOOLING
BECOME  THE FA OF THECOLLAPSEF .
THISANDEC WE ARENOW TWO YEARSIN
BEGINNING OF THEPANDEMIC TIL
LASTFALL ACCORDINGOTHE U.S.
CENSUS SURV.
INDDITION TO TH, THE BIEST
AT WE'VEVEREEN,AND IN
DATA SCIENTIS TEL US THAT A
FULL 2PERCENT OF ALL JOBS D
NORTAMERICA WILLE REMOTEBY
THE END OF TS YEAR.
I DOT INK THE TRD ISOING
ANYWHERE.
I THINK A LO MORE PARENTS E
AT HOME A L MORE OFTE WIT
THR CHILDREN WHH I THINK IS A W
SITUATION.
I DON'THINANYBODY WATCHI
E SHWOUL SATHEY ARE
AUTHORITY FIRES HAVEHANDLED
IS PANDEMIC GHT WE SEE ALLAROUN
INSTITUTE GREAT RESET AND
TRYI TO REMAKE SOCIETY IN
THEIR IMAG BUTHE GOOD THING
IS THAT WHAT MA INNDSOR
EVIL, GOD USES FOR OD, SO WE
HA A GDEN OPPORTUNIT HERE
WHH IS THE BIGGE DEMOGRAPHICOF
WOFORCEAND EITHER STED HE
STAED WORKING REMOTELY AR
MOERS OF SCHOOAGE CHILDREN
SIATION TOKE ADVANTAGE O
THIS AND USIT TOUR OWN
SENDING O KID SOMEWHERE SEVOR E
DOCTRINATED B PPLE WHO
QUE FRKLY OUR ENIES TO A
MORE TRADIONACONSERVATIVE
CHRIIAN WAY OFLIFE.
OUR CHILDREN OUR RALS,OUR
CULTURE, OUR VALUES, WE CAN
BACKO VING PARENTSAND
VALUES.EACHI OURIDS THOSE
>> WHAT YOU SCRID IS
BETIFUL.
YOUR CHILDREN.VERY QUILY, I THI
OUT IS IS WILL KIDSGR
UP TO BE RLD IF THEY SOALIZ
WITHO CLASSMATES.
>> PEOPLHAVEA LOT OF CONCNS
OR WRIESWHEN THEY THINABOUT
HOSCHOOLING.
PUIC EDUCATION  KIND OF KNEW
, IT'S ONL BEEN THE
STDARD FOR ABOUT CENRY AND
PRIO TO AT WE HA OTR WAYS
OF EDUCATINGPEOP.
THGOOD WS I LL PPLE
YOU DON'T HA TOBE AN EXPERT'S
YOU DON'T HA TBE A
TEHER D YOU DON'T HE TO WORRY O
WE HAVE SO MANY WSE CAN DO THAT
INTERN, ALL OF THE BAT, BUT A
LOOF GD COMES WITHWITH ITTO.
WE CAN GET THEM TOINTRAMURAL
SPORTS AND LOT OFPUBLIC SCHOOLSS
AND BAND AND THINGS LE THAT
.OUGH THE SCHL ASELL PRIDE
>> THEY SHOD,OU PAYOR IT.
THK Y FOR JOINING